[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be discussing
the fabled deathly hallows more
specifically i'm going to be discussing
what happened to each of the three halos
after the battle of hogwarts the three
deathly hallows are of course fabled
magical artifacts which pertain to the
tale of the three peverell brothers
antioch cadmus and ignotus the plot
surrounds the three wizard brothers and
their ability to cheat death for a short
period of time after conquering death
personification of death under the guise
of congratulating them awards them with
three gifts the elder wand the
resurrection stone and the invisibility
cloak long story short each brother
chose one of the gifts that death had
presented them ignotus the youngest
chose the invisibility cloak cadmus the
middle brother chose the resurrection
stone
and antioch the eldest chose the elder
wand
from the tale of the three brothers
there were once three brothers who were
traveling along a lonely winding road
twilight in time the brothers reached a
river too deep to wade through and too
dangerous to swim across however these
brothers were learned in the magical
arts and so they simply waved their ones
and made a bridge appear across the
treacherous water they were halfway
across it when they found their path
blocked by a hooded figure
and death spoke to them he was angry
that he had been cheated out of three
new victims four travelers usually
drowned in the river but death was
cunning he pretended to congratulate the
three brothers upon their magic and said
that each had earned a prize for having
been clever enough to evade him these
objects are instrumental in the harry
potter story the invisibility cloak
allowed harry to escape trouble on
numerous occasions the resurrection
stone allowed harry to communicate with
shades of lost loved ones and the elder
wand is well the elder wand one of the
leading plot drivers of the harry potter
story provided that each of these
artifacts is immensely powerful you
might now be wondering what came of them
after the battle of hogwarts what
happened to them after they had played
their part in the story first the elder
wand the fate of the elder wand varies
depending on what you're going by book
or film in the film harry simply snaps
the wand in an effort to make sure that
his powers could never be used for evil
again however this decision was quite
unpopular with fans and is entirely
inconsistent with the events of the book
in the book harry tells dumbledore's
portrait that he's going to lay the one
to rest in tamur's tomb and pushing the
other wand he told dumbledore who was
watching him with enormous affection and
admiration back where it came from it
can stay there if i die a natural death
like ignotus its power will be broken
won't it the previous master will never
have been defeated that'll be the end of
it and that covers the elder wand if we
go by existing cannon then it appears
that the wand simply stayed there now
for the stone the last we saw of the
stone was in the forbidden forest when
harry uses it to produce images of his
mother father and others while the stone
was previously thought to bring back the
dead in reality it only brings back a
shade of these people it has been
expressed the shades produced are less
substantial than living bodies but much
more than ghosts in a rather
anticlimactic fashion harry simply drops
the stone in the forest and its
whereabouts are still unknown to this
day the resurrection stone slipped from
between his numb fingers and out of the
corner of his eye he saw his parents
sirius and lupin vanish as he stepped
forward into the fire light
the thing is harry had no interest in
keeping the stone anymore and to a
passerby it would be just another rock
on the forest floor in fact according to
an interview with jk rowling the stone
eventually got stepped on by a centaur
being further buried into the ground
so that's the wand in the stone spoken
for but what of the cloak as of the
cloak well it simply remained in harry's
possession harry never felt that the
existence of the cloak posed much of a
threat so he didn't feel compelled to
destroy or hide it in fact the cloak was
a potter family heirloom and he likely
passed it on to his son after he died
and that's it for this video did you
guys know what had happened to the
hallows let me know in the comment
section below until next time my father
will hear about this
[Music]
you